[Música]
y
el tema de los incendios aquí en
california continúa siendo gravísimo no
sólo por la calidad del aire que es la
peor en los últimos 30 años se ha
prohibido a las personas adultas y en
general a todas las personas que nos
salgan sobre todo en las áreas más
contaminadas por los fuertes incendios
los ángeles tienen un incendio el
incendio podcast que está en las
montañas conocidas como la sierra madre
que es donde el incendio más se ha
acercado a la ciudad áreas como monrovia
glendora y pasadena han sido seriamente
afectadas y han visto que miles de
personas sean evacuadas además para los
medios de comunicación este es un
incendio gravísimo se acercó
peligrosamente en las últimas horas a la
montaña wilson que donde están todas las
antenas de los canales de televisión y
también de las radios entonces los
bomberos tuvieron que trabajar de manera
extra cerca de 1200 bomberos tuvieron
que batallar fuertemente para que no se
quemarán estas antenas
[Música]
brasil arde y las llamas devoran día
tras día su flora y su fauna en el
pantanal que es el humedal más grande
del mundo ya son 15 mil focos y casi 3
millones de hectáreas destruidas lo que
equivale a un territorio como bélgica
los animales en extinción como los
jaguares también están sufriendo las
imágenes de esos animales agonizando o
calcinados han conmocionado la opinión
pública de brasil la amazonía tampoco
está mejor en lo que va de año los
incendios han aumentado un 11 por ciento
ya son 64 mil los focos de incendio y de
ellos 50.000 sólo en los últimos dos
meses fiel a su visión negacionista el
presidente de jair bolsonaro ha dicho
que brasil es el país que más defiende
su medio ambiente y que puede estar de
enhorabuena sin embargo los gobiernos de
ocho países incluida francia han enviado
una carta abierta al vicepresidente a
milton morado mostrando su preocupación
y protestando contra la política
medioambiental de brasil
[Música]
bolivia está sufriendo una vez más el
embate de los incendios forestales que
ya han consumido unas 500.000 hectáreas
de bosques y pastizales si bien este
número no se asemeja a las más de 2.5
millones de hectáreas quemadas el año
pasado el tema reviste mucha
preocupación en el país por eso la
presidenta jeanine áñez ha decidido
declarar emergencia nacional para
atender esta crisis y ha aprobado un
decreto que había sido aprobado por el
ex presidente evo morales y que permitía
las quemas en el departamento de beni
los activistas y ecologistas han
señalado que esta droga toria es
insuficiente porque existen al menos una
decena de normas que permiten estos
incendios en el país para habilitar
tierras para la ganadería y la
agricultura además señalan que este
decreto solo estaba enfocado a benny
mientras que la mayor cantidad de los
incendios se sitúa en santa cruz donde
se encuentra el parque noel kempff
mercado una reserva de importancia
mundial
[Música]